right now I turn to my right and so many
guests brockman as you know complain
that I'm sitting higher than them it's
show but this guest has no such
complaint he is the four-time Pro Bowl
offensive lineman formerly of the Texans
now the Seattle Seahawks Dwayne Branca
to see you sir
you got it so what is this time of year
like for you what are you doing right
now uh working out relaxing my wife is
uh almost eight months pregnant so oh
that's uh taking up a lot of my time
what number child is is for you uh
number three for me this is our first
one you had to think about that for a
second okay this is your this is your
third kid yeah okay first one but first
one with your wife got it
so now um you're doing that right now
you're working out and you're getting
ready for a seattle season that a lot of
people doing or wondering it's gonna
look like right now are you one of those
people not wondering i'm pretty
confident and and what we can do it's
definitely gonna be different though but
sure with uh with two of the the
mainstays that were there they helped
build that culture mmm those guys headed
out it's gonna be different okay so what
is the culture gonna be best you can
tell still gonna be tough team be a
tough tough locker room still a lot of
personalities on their team i think the
defense will will definitely have a new
look but still be competitive still yet
to see there's still a lot of move to be
made still got a jeff coming up so you
know it's a lot that'll change i think
over the next month or two but uh i
think what we're still competing in a
few s now I know that that you can't get
in there right now they can't get you in
there right now you're not gonna be able
to really have much of conversation with
your new offensive coordinator or your
new line coach pretty much too what do
you what is this
can you tell Seattle fans or us what
what this offense is going to look like
compared to what we have seen in Seattle
I don't know what what the plan is for
the offense you know we have a new
coordinator having new rough semana
coach I've spoken with him very briefly
okay um but I think you know we still
have number 300 Center so you know you
can expect to see a lot from Russell
Wilson I think the office of lion will
definitely play a huge part in our
success I'm looking forward to working
with the guys a full season
being able to go through a complete
offseason with those guys and and better
myself as as well as help those guys as
well along the way and um we're gonna be
good okay gonna be good well again it's
just a lot of people doubt that to be
very honest with you yeah because again
I know you're just new to the program
they're traded in the middle of the
season last year acquired in the middle
of the season last year but just it's
difficult for Seattle fans to wrap their
hands around the idea that the the faces
that have been the outside of Russell
Wilson and Marshawn Lynch that some of
them are just one-by-one being sent
packing and the identity of the team's
gonna change that's understandable
I think you have guys like which is
Herman who's been a perennial Pro Bowler
been one of the best quarterbacks in
league throughout his career
I got like Michael Bennett you know
who's been you know gotten out to the
quarterback as well as anybody you get
to guys like that who head out you know
it's it definitely raises some questions
and that's very understandable I could
just tell you from my short time there's
a lot of talent on the team there's a
lot of depth on our team I think and I
trust the staff there I trust the
coaches there and and and the young
players that come in and they'll put
them in position and be successful like
I said I'm gonna do my best to it to be
the best player I can be the unit that
I'm in control of is offensive line and
I'm gonna do my best to make sure we're
the most competitive unit on my team you
know so I can definitely understand the
doubts that go along with everything
that has transpired but from a veteran
if someone's played a lot of football in
his league I think I'm very very
optimistic about our season Dwane Brown
here on the Rich Eisen show four-time
Pro Bowl or 10 years in the National
Football League coming out of Virginia
Tech now of Seattle formerly of the
Texans here on the Rich Eisen show when
you said still a lot of personalities in
that locker room and you named two guys
in Richard Sherman and Michael Bennett
being sent away there has been part of
the conversation over the weekend that
Seattle shipped out both these guys by
trade and by cutting because of what
they were doing in the locker room how
they were outspoken
so about issues of societal issues what
do you say to that Dwane Brown I don't
think there's any truth to that I think
if you look at the way the organization
has backed their players through
everything that they've spoken out about
through things that they went through ie
Michael Bennett in Las Vegas you look at
everything that's happened they
definitely backed him 110 percent I
think in the time that I spent there I
spent a couple months there there was
never a time where I felt like the
support for players that spoke out
wasn't there Pete Carroll and everyone
involved
they love the players they love what God
stands for they don't want just robotic
guys that just come in and work they
want guys that that stand for something
bigger than themselves and I don't think
that that was the the the matter at all
as to why they moved on I think it was
more so financial things like that but
uh no I don't believe that at all well
when I heard that theory being floated
by some in my business I thought of two
people I thought of Doug Baldwin yeah
he's still on the team I thought of you
yeah I don't think I would be there
though the case right I thought well the
question is is are you there because
that was the case in Houston do you
think you were sent away to Seattle
because you were outspoken on these
issues um I think it was a couple of
things but uh I think the things I spoke
out against were not just the Seidel
issues but kind of what was going on in
house and uh you know a lot of people
didn't want to hear it you know even if
it was the truth in your face
you know a lot of people don't to hear
that so but uh you know it could have
been the reason I don't know if they
chose that destination specifically
because of the the culture there but if
so then I'm all for it so for those who
might not be familiar what were you
talking about in Houston oh I think the
comments that were made by owner you
know I talked about that because it came
out right when I
into the holdout what he was being
quoted is saying in the ESPN Oracle VM
quote is saying can't let the enemies
run to prison
in regards to the the players kneeling
for the anthem and protesting police
injustice and police brutality well I
think you know what Bob McNair said he
was referring to was not the players he
was referring to other owners in the
league when talking about that yeah yeah
right
no that wasn't that wasn't that wasn't
the case he was talking about the
players I mean we actually had a meeting
the team meeting about it and you know
he kind of went in depth a little bit
more than he should have and exposed
what he really meant no I wasn't okay
with it and so you think that part of
that was why you were sent to Seattle
when it was all said and done yeah thank
part of me and you don't think being in
Seattle having that sort of vocal role
as a player is something that's viewed
as a negative it's what you're saying no
I don't think that viewed as a negative
because I think everyone on that staff
is aware of what's going on they're not
blind to it there are a lot of people
that live in the bubble of just coming
to work forgetting everything that's
going on and society and working and
forgetting about it but I don't think
people there live in that bubble I think
that they are very aware of what's going
on so when a player or a group of
players speak up against it they're
there for word because they understand
that it's it's reality Dwane Brown here
on the Rich Eisen show and we had Kenny
Stills here last week and he's been very
active in his community in South Florida
and he went on a tour of the deep south
to shine more of a light on this issue
as well as seeing what's going on in
certain communities to fix the issue
best we can actually use that phrase
where do you stand on people who think
that you should stand during the
national anthem as opposed to using it
as a moment to bring out other issues Oh
everyone has their opinion and I mean
for the people that say I watch this
game for entertainment
watch this game you're not supposed to
bring that stuff your political views to
work things like that this is a reality
for a lot of us and we're not able to
escape reality at all times you know
even though even though some people may
want to when they watch football is an
escape from reality we're not able to do
that for a lot of us when we take off
our helmet shoulder pads and leave our
facility a lot of us have viewed as
people that aren't in our position and
just to be and viewed as just another
black man in America and so when you
have things that are going on in this
country that touch some of our friends
touch some of our families you know
family members things like that I feel
like we have to use our platform for
this it's no different than what's going
on in the NBA would you know
shut up and dribble with a total brawn
it's you know everyone wants us to be in
this box but we don't want to be there
so I'm gonna continue to do my job at
the highest level that I am but also I'm
going to speak out against things that I
feel at wrong Dwane Brown here on the
Rich Eisen show and in terms of doing
the job that you do at a high level what
do you think about what is your other
colleagues think about when everybody
talks about how Russell Wilson's running
for his life behind the offensive line
how did you guys take that conversation
yeah it hurts it hurts we will continue
to compete you know it's uh it's it's
something we have to continue to get
better at
we got the community block better we all
continue to create that pocket and it's
a you know there were moments where we
did block it pretty well but sometimes
he wants to improvise and get out of the
pocket and you know as an offensive
lineman at that point it's not it's not
much you can do you know so you know
it's just something that we're all we're
all continuing to get in sync with and
on and you can expect a better product
in 2018-2019 that's right Dwane Brown
again this has been an interesting chat
to say the least so you're you're down
here you go up to Seattle for OTAs and
things of that nature and then you get
ready to play football against Richard
Sherman I know you you'll be on the
field obviously with him
standing outside that wide there I mean
I know this is first blush right now but
what do you think those two visits at
his house and him back in Seattle is
gonna be like it's gonna be intense
the time I spend with Richard I can say
he's a warrior first class warrior a
great great dude and uh you know
somebody I'm definitely gonna miss in
that locker room and you know I think
part of the reason that he went there
was to to be able to compete against his
old team two times a year and uh
I respect it I respect it I mean all I
can say is I probably won't have many
encounters with them but if I do pull
around a corner it's gonna be you you
gotta get tomorrow right you know it's
all love with me it's all love with me
man I love rich so when you're pulling
around the corner and you see cornerback
out there not man that's fine that's
good as fun that's good at ease so sorry
certainly if it's got a number 25 on it
against San Francisco I'm not I'm not
I'm not zone annoyed with the survey
don't put birth my mouth I'm not going
out there trying to kill him
but if I do BB dial it up then it's
always a good time hey Duane thanks for
coming in here you are welcome anytime
certainly you know what you're local oh
by the way did you didn't play with tie
rod at Virginia Tech or did my senior
year well karo a fourth year so before I
let you go it looks like he's got we
don't know what the Browns are gonna do
it at in the draft at quarterback but it
sure looks like he has got a heck of an
opportunity here what do you think he
can good do you think he can be in this
league Dwayne I've always been a huge
fan of tal rice when he first moved to
Buffalo from Baltimore I told everyone
he's gonna light it up and sure enough
he's he's had a heck of a career so far
I'm happy that he's going somewhere that
really really appreciates him I'm happy
that they've loaded him up with some
weapons for him to utilize and I think
he's gonna do great I mean it's how I
was a heck of a talent man so salute to
him I think he's gonna do well yeah I
mean Josh Gordon Jarvis Landry want to
talk about you know head on a swivel
yeah and he also he built up a pretty
good line over there you know so of
things that good opportunity for him
yeah
Joe Thomas is thinking about hanging him
up right now
I mean he's he's one of the best of all
time I know and he's sitting there he
says that what what they're doing right
now is not gonna have any effect on him
but you have to think maybe it will you
never know it's tough it's tough
decision to me but but just I mean one
last one for you ramping it up your 10
National Football League what does it
take for you
this is year 11 for me Cumberland oh
okay um just continue to work continue
to work on my craft I mean but I mean in
terms of the weight room and what you're
doing right now I mean it's it's an
everyday thing everyday thing yeah I
know do you get the offseason gets
shorter and shorter you know you have to
do more you don't you don't get to take
as much time off you know guys are
getting younger they're getting faster
stronger you know so I always got to be
able to compete at Dwayne brown 76 on
Twitter we'll chat again soon thanks for
have you got it the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience